المنتخب الياباني الذي تاهل بصداره مجموعه
الموت الى ثمن نهائي مونديال قطر يواجه
هذه المره تحديا من نوع اخر عندما يلتقي
الكرواتيا وصيفه المونديال السابق المنتخب
الياباني الذي حقق فوزان تاريخيين على
اسبانيا والمانيا منحه طبعا صداره مجموعه
وكذلك اقصى المنشات الالماني سيحاول تكرار
انجازه ولملئ الاطاح برفاق مودريتش
وتاهل لاول مره الى ربع نهائي كاس العالم
نعم سيكون غياب المدافع اذا كره مؤثرا على
منتخب اليابان ولكن جماهير الساموراي تلقت
اخبارا ساره بجاهزيه المدافع توميانسو هذا
اللاعب الذي تالق مع ارسنال بل هو احد
افضل لاعبي المنتخب الياباني في السنوات
الاخيره بالتالي ستكون الساموراي قويه
ايضا بوجود هذا المدافع الذي عانى من
اصابه خفيفه ولكن الان هو جاهز 100 للعبه
اساسيا مع منتخب اليابان بالتالي ستكون
مباراه صعبه تتحدث عن مودريتش وتتحدث عن
المدرب الخبير ثالث تتحدث عن بيرزيش تتحدث
الاسماء الوازنه والخبيره في منتخب
كرواتيا يقابلها طبعا الكمبيوتر الياباني
الذي اثبت حضوره
سواء الاساسيه او الاحتياطيين
[موسيقى]
في المقابل تبدو مواجهه البرازيل امام
كوريا الجنوبيه ساسه على الورق لرقص
السامبا طبعا هم الفريق الاوفر حظا للتاهل
ولكن المنتخب الكوري استطاع ان يقصد
اوروغواي وكذلك الكاميرون من الدور الاول
فاستغلب على المنتخب البرتغالي وهذا مؤشر
جديد انا شمشون الكوري في هذا المونديال
قادرون على تحقيق مفاجاه جديده ولما
لاقصاء البرازيل
[موسيقى]
بالطبع المنتخب البرازيلي يعاني من غيابات
مؤثره تتحدث عن المهاجم خيسوس تتحدث كذلك
عن الظاهر الايسر تلاس حتى نيمار الاخبار
تقول انه ليس جاهزا مئه بالمئه ليلعب
بالكامل عافيته حتى وان شارك لدقائق معينه
في المباراه يبقى ذلك عنصر ودافعا لمنتخب
كوريا الجنوبيه لتحقيق المفاجاه كما ذكرنا
لكن في النهايه المنتخب البرازيلي هو
الاوفر حظا
[موسيقى]
يمتلك اسماء كبيره واسماء وازنه في الفريق
هنالك طبعا المهاجر هنالك رودريجو هنالك
انطوني كذلك في خط الوسط نتحدث عن
كاسيميرو في خط الدفاع القائد كذلك الحارس
اليسون كل هذه الاسماء التي تمتلك خبره
كبيره في الملاعب ااه العالميه وكذلك كما
قلنا الاوروبيه تستطيع ان ترجح كافه
المنتخب البرازيلي لذلك هي مباراه صعب على
الطرفين ولكن في النهايه اتوقعها برازيليه
والمنطق سيطلب نفسه خاصه وان المنتخب
البرازيلي يريد اعاده الكاس مجددا الى
خزائنه وهو صاحب الرقم القياسي بالفوز
بعدد البطولات صح ان المنتخب الكوري هو
الخصم والمنافس وهو الذي تاهل لمره واحده
الى نصف نهائي المونديال 2002 في كوريا
الجنوبيه المونديال الشهير والتاريخيه
[تصفيق]